[Music]
the main difficulties of working with
any vulnerable or fragile work of
cultural heritage is the respect you
have to have for that object technology
is at a point right now where we can
record the surface of an object down to
fractions of a millimeter and it's
through this kind of understanding that
allows you to communicate across time
and across cultures and the task of
heritage protection and preservation is
a real challenge
the mission of factum foundation is to
record cultural heritage so in the event
that there's a disaster or an accident
we have the data to know what was there
exactly as it is we're pioneering a
number of methods to return that
information into the physical world
we're doing CNC milling we're doing 3d
printing but we're trying to go beyond
that a facsimile of the Borg are in each
Apple the facsimile of the tomb of
Tutankhamen in the Valley of the Kings
an exact facsimile of Vera nasals
wedding at Cana
[Music]
[Applause]
the biggest project that's going on at
the moment is an exact facsimile of the
tomb of Seti the first which will be
given to the people of Egypt as soon as
it's finished two hundred years ago the
concern was not one of preservation the
concern was one of Indiana Jones and
discovery and excitement and cultural
acquisitions the tombs in the Valley of
the Kings lasted successfully for three
thousand three and a half thousand years
but since they've been visited they
start to decline and decay rapidly
I think the facsimile is opening up a
whole new level of possibility for
display preservation conservation
restoration communication dissemination
of what's important about these objects
if only we can preserve it like it is
and document it and hand it on to future
generations then there's hope as long as
prosthesis have been around people have
been really focusing on making it look
like a hand and move like a hand but our
hand is not just a grabber a hand is a
touch
his touch that engages you if the world
is touched that engages you with people
a prosthesis without touch is a tool
that giving touch we're giving back a
hand I worked in a factory setting
before I lost my life I was doing some
cleaning under out from underneath a
shredder type machine and grab material
that was in my hand and pulled my hand
into the machine I didn't think that I'd
ever have the sensation of touch or
anything back again and then my
prosthetics told me about the research
program up here in Cleveland they hope
to be able to give me the sense of touch
[Music]
the research that we've been doing is
reconnecting the man to the machine
basically learning how to take what the
prosthesis feels and translates that the
person using it feels it for the brain
to feel touch as being their actual hand
is really important that we activators
stimulate the wires that the brain
always used to get from the hand
what we do is we implant cuff electrodes
and then we apply really tiny amounts of
current that activate those wires and
that information then goes to the brain
so we've been learning how to place this
information on that nerve so the brain
thinks it's his hand they can feel not
just buzzing but also a touch of
pressure like somebody putting a finger
on their hand and in fact we've been
able to see that intensity of the
artificial stimulation mimics the intact
hand saw big block the first time they
put sensation on everything it was just
incredible it was I could actually feel
an area in my hand a certain area
tingling and vibrations and stuff small
soft block I said just an incredible
feeling
bringing the prosthetic home with the
sensory hand on it and being able to
feel and everything's changed life
considerably it's just little things
that people take for granted brushing
teeth to be able to hold the toothpaste
and be able to squeeze and tell how hard
I'm squeezing to say don't squeeze and I
go every place it makes it a lot easier
we're at the point where subjects can
use their prosthesis at home they can
have sensation while they're at home it
makes them two-handed again it brings
back their hand and makes them whole
[Music]
yes I'll do some training I worked with
dogs to train them to go into an MRI
scanner and try to figure out what makes
them tick and what they're thinking
my name is Gregory Berns
I'm a neuroscientist at Emory University
in Atlanta Georgia I've grown up with
dogs and I've lived with dogs pretty
much my whole life one of my favorite
dogs had passed away in the back of my
mind I started wondering did that dog
love me in the way that I loved him and
that was really the beginning of it all
of these basic things that we've begun
to sort out in humans at least in human
brands we want to do in dogs if dogs can
be trained to go into an MRI machine
then maybe we could figure out what
they're actually thinking so we have a
dog in a scanner that's Katie and she is
a veteran of the project this is
probably about the 15th time she's done
this
[Music]
just having the idea of ok well let's
train dogs on a scanner it wasn't
immediately apparent how you would go
about doing that and and MRI scanners
are not the most pleasant environments
Kali is the little black terrier who was
the first dog to train for the dog
project I built a simulator of an MRI so
this is the simulator that I built here
in my basement then we started adding in
recordings of the scanner noise which is
actually quite loud we just started
working with you know treats and
positive reinforcement to see if we
could get her to go into this thing that
actually proved to be pretty easy and
then so what we did was we kind of put
out word of mouth do you want to join
this project you want to train your dogs
for an MRI and you know maybe figure out
what they're thinking the purpose of
this is to go through a number of
exercises including basic obedience as
well as how they react to the obstacles
when we hold the tryouts it lets us weed
out the dogs that we don't think would
enjoy doing this one of the benefits
then of having more participants as it
gives you statistical power you can
start to average dogs brains together
and get a better sense for what's
happening I started wondering very
seriously if we could really finally
answer this question do dogs essentially
like us just for the social bond and not
about the food
and what we found was looking at the
reward system that almost all the dogs
had equal responses both to food as well
as praise and even a few dogs like the
praise and more the things that we were
finding about the dog's brain in many
ways confirm I think what people know in
their hearts about how dogs behave and
why they behave the way I think about
dogs is in many ways they're the
ambassadors to the animal world they're
not that different from many of the
other mammals out there and so I suspect
that a lot of what we find is dogs
probably holds true for pretty much any
mammal
I was the snowflake consultant on the
movie frozen they wanted to get all the
snowflakes right and so they asked me
you know how they grow and I was very
pleased when the movie came out they all
looked like real snowflakes none of them
were eight-sided they're all sick
sighted and so good job my name is Ken
Lee bricked and I'm a professor of
physics here at Cal Tech and I also grow
snowflakes well I got into physics very
early I've been doing that most of my
life maybe about 20 years ago I just got
interested in how crystals grow and that
sort of led me to ice and to snowflakes
we still don't exactly understand why
they look like they do so it's kind of
fun to think about to make a snowflake
in the lab you start with water and
water vapor and you've got to get
everything cold and basically start a
crystal growing and I'll kind of blow
moist air down onto it and it just
absorbs water vapor from the air and
starts to grow and I can do this piece
of glass and so just watch it girl I'm
the only one that makes no flakes like
this in the lab when you start to look
really carefully at how a snowflake
works you find you don't understand it
and there's a lot going on you dig
deeper there's more and more stuff and
it's it's really very interesting to me
anyway I love to go out and and and sort
of hunt for snowflakes because these
beautiful works of art are just falling
all over and you pick a few of them up
and photograph them and the rest of them
you just trample on at the end of the
day I'm trying to understand how atoms
and molecules fit together to form
crystals and by studying snowflake
slowly you figure things out that are
that are useful one snowflake at a time
[Music]